♫ music ♫
My name is Kaitlyn Hova.
I'm a software engineer, neuroscientist,
and a musician.
I also have synesthesia.
Synesthesia is a blending of the senses.
1 in 23 people have a form of it.
For me, when I hear,
specific musical notes,
I see specific colours...
...and these colours are much brighter...
at night.
♫ violin ♫
What you're seeing in front of me,
is a lot like what I see
...when I hear this music.
♫ violin ♫
Each one of these coloured
lights corresponds to a particular note
The colours are always the same.
♫ violin ♫
I've seen these colours my whole life.
But I didn't know that was unusual,
until I was 21 years old.
♫ violin ♫
It was the final music theory course,
for my music major,
that, at the end of my class,
my professor mentioned
that some people can physically
see sounds as colours.
♫ violin ♫
And to me... I thought... duh...
...and everyone in the classroom
turned to look at me.
♫ violin ♫
We did tests,
where they played notes on the piano
...and I told them what colour it was...
♫ violin ♫
...and at that point I knew
that I had synesthesia.
♫ violin ♫
Synesthesia can manifest itself
in so many different ways.
It can blend itself together
vision, taste, smell, sound...
...it can be almost anything.
♫ violin ♫
But for me... it's always been about
the colours in music.
♫ violin ♫
Synesthesia makes the music
a very visual experience.
♫ violin ♫
Now, listening to a piece
is sort of like watching a video.
♫ violin ♫
I can listen to it over and over again...
...and focus on different colours and patterns,
each time.
♫ violin ♫
Now... if you turn to face the city...
(using arrows on top left corner of video)
you can really step into my shoes,
and see what I see.
♫ violin ♫
I'm not sure what I would do,
if my synesthesia went away.
But, I'm sure that the world
would look a lot different.
♫ violin ♫
♫ music ♫